[Music]
moving on now to tonight's star-studded
hurricane relief telethon the show will
be hosted from three different locations
New York Nashville and Los Angeles and
that is where our nischelle Turner is
with a preview hi Nichelle hey Nance
here at Universal Studios stars like
Oprah Winfrey George Clooney and Julia
Roberts are set to man the phones for
hand in hand a benefit for hurricane
relief now they just added Leonardo
DiCaprio and Justin Timberlake and
released a promo with an emotional
Selena Gomez we are going to get through
all the storms that confront us that's
how we are going to do it together
candidate today at GMA studios in New
York they were gearing up to broadcast
live across 17 networks our crew is hard
at work getting the telethon set
upstairs Justin Bieber will be here in
LA his and Ariana Grande's manager
Scooter Braun who set up the benefit for
Manchester back in June is putting
together tonight's telethon it will also
feature Kelly Rowland everyone's
blocking out for an hour and letting us
go commercial free to raise as much
money as possible it's never been a time
where I've seen so many people come
together
plenty more musicians will be there for
the one hour show so expect some big
performances and you'll also see this
guy anybody who has watched what's
happened in Houston now in Florida and
really up into the Carolinas my hometown
of Charleston is bloody ready yeah can't
help but be moved and everybody looks
for an opportunity to be able to help
now I talked to Stephen here in downtown
Los Angeles today because he's hosting
this little event this weekend ok this
big event this weekend the Emmys and
this morning the red carpet was rolled
out and the funny man who was also
nominated has big plans for TV's biggest
night who should be afraid in the
audience we should be afraid yes no one
no one should be afraid to play nice
listen sometimes those folks in the
front row they get it oh yeah yeah yeah
Reese Witherspoon has it coming ok I'm
coming for your Reese
[Music]